[Music]
are we gonna get a dead hole three it'll
be up to the fans and people whether or
not they go see this movie but if it
were up to me the answer would certainly
be yes but we don't count our chickens
before they hatch in February next year
now that it's all done it's wrapped what
can you tell us about what can you tease
it's new for the fence because
everyone's chomping a bit for any little
morsel you can give us anything of what
I couldn't say that's new that I won't
get tranq dart in the neck for telling
you I directed a movie in its it's much
more loyal to to the original comic the
next men three which told the dark
beatings story it's a movie that
involves let's say extraterrestrial
characters which is not something that
we've done in the x-men franchise before
and it's something that was a huge part
is a huge part of the Dark Phoenix saga
in the comics reggaeton is a lot darker
too
the tone is definitely I don't know if I
would say it's darker but it's more
intense and it's more real I think and
grounded and hopefully more relatable a
little less operatic than we've been in
the past
[Applause]
[Music]